[Musica]
buongiorno a tutti e bellissimo tornare
in mezzo alle persone a parlare dopo
quasi due anni sono due anni che non
vado ad una conferenza e faccio questa
cosa
oggi veramente vorrei provare
partendo dalla dal tema di oggi
fondamentalmente dall'idea di pirandello
da quel così è se vi pare vorrei provare
a buttare giù qualche idea su anche
quale sia il ruolo della fisica perché
sono un fisico ma anche della scienza
nella società di oggi la prende un po
larga però proverò farvi vedere che
forse qualcosa lo possiamo dire
fondamentalmente pirandello
semplificando molto ci dice non esiste
una realtà oggettiva quello che esiste
soltanto la interpretazione personale
della realtà ognuno si costruisce la sua
e questo non potrebbe essere più in
antitesi con quello che fa il fisico con
quello che fa lo scienziato la fisica si
pone come era grande e rivelatrice di
tutti i fenomeni naturali
vuole cercare di dare una lettura
oggettiva di ciò che vede nella natura
nel cielo negli atomi eccetera però
proviamo a fare un piccolo piccolissimo
esercizio niente di complicato
ovviamente ma se prendiamo quel se vi
pare e lo trasformiamo in se vi appare
allora veramente
quasi abbiamo la tag line del lavoro
della fim del fisico prendo quello che
vedo è quello è il mio punto di partenza
la mia pietra di paragone dal quale
iniziare a spiegare tutto quanto è quel
tutto quanto non lo possiamo negare è
assolutamente difficile ingarbugliato
tante volte incomprensibile
per avere la cifra di questo basta per
rifarmi a quello che mi viene risposto
la reazione che vedono le persone quando
mi viene chiesto ma di che cosa ti
occupi ma che cosa fai nella vita e la
reazione
90 volte su 100 è
se un fisico ma caspita non ci ho mai
capito niente di fisica la fisica
proprio negato il mio professore mi
odiava mi ha sempre dato 4
eppure purtroppo è questa l'idea che
abbiamo della fisica perché
lasciamo stare lì chi sia la colpa ma
tanti la percepiscono in questo modo la
fisica la percepiscono come
un'accozzaglia di formule
incomprensibile ingarbugliata unicamente
da studiare a memoria
mi viene da dire qualcosa di più
la seconda domanda dopo che mi viene
chiesto di che cosa ti occupi alla
risposta solitamente segue
la seconda domanda che è ma scusa ma a
che cosa serve quello che fai
cioè qual è il ritorno pratico il
ritorno pratico tante volte non c'è
certe volte mi viene un po da pensare
che se andiamo unicamente a cercare
la risposta a ciò che facciamo
nell'utilità di quella cosa cioè come
posso sfruttare effettivamente quello
che tu hai scoperto allora
effettivamente forse ci dobbiamo fare
qualche domanda
io non voglio declinare il lavoro del
fisico non voglio declinare l'attività
di ricerca come un unico facciamo
qualcosa che ci possa poi dare un
ritorno malavoglia declinare in un altro
in un altro modo per farlo vorrei
partire da un piccolo aneddoto qualche
anno fa stavo finendo il mio dottorato
in olanda e ho avuto l'opportunità di
essere presente a una discussione di una
tesi di dottorato
di un collega e nel comitato di
valutazione di questa tesi di dottorato
c'era un professore molto famoso che è
il professor ben fair inca si dice
proprio così con questa per capire la
bellezza della lingua olandese questa
solitamente professore persona molto
brillante però in quel momento
alla fine della discussione ha detto una
cosa che mi ha profondamente colpito ha
detto al mio collega vedi tu oggi hai
finito un percorso tutto quello che ti
potevamo insegnare per diventare un
ricercatore tel abbiamo insegnato sai
tutto adesso se vorrai andare avanti
l'unica cosa che ti servirà sarà
unicamente la tua curiosità
ecco come il declino quello che facciamo
noi la fisica non è un'accozzaglia di
formule la fisica è il risultato della
curiosità umana di fronte ai fenomeni
naturali e il bisogno che noi abbiamo
quando vediamo qualcosa che non
comprendiamo il bisogno di andare ad
aprire sviscerare comprendere il
meccanismo che c'è sotto
e se volete questo si traduce in un
attività che forse è molto diversa da
quanto ci aspettiamo nella società di
oggi dove dinamismo cambiamento
novità sono sempre all'ordine del giorno
l'attività del fisica un'attività più
lunga richiede tempo richiede pazienza
porta disperazione ma questa è tutta
un'altra questione
richiede tanta tanta pazienza
soprattutto e tanti stimoli agli stimoli
si trovano nei piccoli esperimenti che
si fanno ogni giorno se volete è un po
come il lavoro di un archeologo che sta
cercando di scavare un enorme mosaico
romano di una domus e questo mosaico di
questo mosaico l'archeologo non sa nulla
sa soltanto che dovrebbe essere lì
perché qualcuno è riuscito a delimitare
il perimetro della domus si aspetta che
stia lì ma non sa dove sta allora pian
piano con il pennellino un passettino in
avanti passettino di lato comincia a
vedere qualche tessera
va avanti sempre di più magari troverà
delle zone in cui mosaicon non c'è
proprio oppure danneggiato magari
troverà delle zone in cui il mosaico e
splendente con un disegno incredibile mi
vengono in mente i mosaici che ho visto
al museo di aquileia per quando quando
in mente questa cosa questo fa alla
fisica questo fa la scienza va avanti
per piccoli passi uno avanti uno di lato
tante volte uno indietro due indietro ma
sempre con l'idea più grande che è
quella di e scavare cioè capire
profondamente un fenomeno
l'approccio che fondamentalmente 400
anni fa galileo ci ha dato e che è
ancora valido e ancora potentissimo è
quello di dire tu vedi qualcosa nella
natura benissimo allora
più che fare come si era sempre fatto
nella filosofia aristotelica mi
perdoneranno gli esperti presenti se
faccio questa riduzione questa
semplificazione ma
più che speculare nella tua testa
sulla natura di quel fenomeno guardalo
quel fenomeno interpreta lo capisci lo
fissa il tuo esperimento come pietra di
paragone per la comprensione della
realtà e per descrivere i tuoi risultati
utilizza il linguaggio più potente e
universale che abbiamo cioè la
matematica la matematica ci permette di
dare una descrizione di tutti i fenomeni
in modo
90 volte su 100 lineare ma soprattutto
comprensibile a tutti e universale sarà
sempre lì
questo approccio ha funzionato benissimo
ha funzionato benissimo per secoli ma
funziona talmente bene che alla fine del
xix secolo inizi del ventesimo quando
tutti i fenomeni della scala
macroscopica ossia di quello che vediamo
tutti i giorni tutti i fenomeni erano
stati spiegati e c'era qualcuno che era
arrivato a dire ma cosa facciamo dopo
che abbiamo finito tutto cioè non c'è
più niente da dire da spiegare
probabilmente prendiamo la fisica la
mettiamo lì non scaffale fine chiudiamo
in realtà non c'è mai una fine perché le
persone hanno cominciato a fare piccoli
esperimenti non guardando piu alla
natura macroscopica cioè al moto di
quello che vediamo tutti i giorni ma
andando a vedere nel piccolo nei
costituenti della materia cioè negli
atomi nelle molecole nelle particelle
subatomiche
e più si scavava più venivano fuori cose
che erano in apparente contrasto con
tutte le teorie i modelli sviluppati nei
300 anni precedenti allora si era detto
ma scusate ma allora tutto quanto è da
buttare tutto quello che abbiamo fatto
fin qui lo buttiamo no non lo buttiamo
ma prendiamo atto che sulla scala del
microscopico cioè degli atomi e delle
molecole la materia si comporta in modo
completamente diverso prendiamone atto
riscriviamo un nuovo modello così
scriviamo una nuova teoria
e così è nata la meccanica quantistica
cioè la meccanica che spiega il moto di
queste particelle microscopiche la
meccanica quantistica che se volete è
ancora più complessa intricata e anti
intuitiva di quello che è la fisica
classica normale degli oggetti
macroscopici
questo perché
questa è qualcosa di profondamente
lontano dalla nostra esperienza
personale su quella scala alla natura ha
messo una maschera
che ci ha completamente nascosto il
comportamento della materia su quelle
scale ma mi viene da dire quella
maschera forse ce la siamo messa a noi
perché ci eravamo costruiti un modello
di natura e con quel modello
pretendevamo di vedere qualsiasi e
spiegare qualsiasi cosa non ha
funzionato abbiamo dovuto toglierci
quella maschera e prendere atto che
laggiù le cose funzionano diversamente
un grande fisico del ventesimo secolo
richard feynman diceva chi asserisce di
aver capito completamente la meccanica
quantistica
molto probabilmente non ha capito la
meccanica quantistica perché è veramente
qualcosa di lontano da noi ma lo stesso
fi ma dicevo un'altra cosa diceva adesso
che stiamo capendo come funziona la
materia laggiù in fondo a queste scale
piccole possiamo sfruttare la libertà di
manovra che ci viene concessa che cosa
significa fi man ha usato l'espressione
del ris plenty of rome and the bottom
c'è un sacco di spazio laggiù in fondo è
laggiù in fondo significa che se noi
sappiamo controllare le posizioni il
comportamento degli atomi e delle
molecole possiamo realizzare qualcosa di
nuovo qualcosa di inaspettato qualcosa
che in natura non c'è ma che noi
possiamo realizzare
in modo tale che abbia certe proprietà
vi faccio un piccolo esempio tutti
abbiamo in mente uno dei metalli più
comuni non proprio comuni ma tutti
abbiamo un'idea di questo loro
l'oro e il metallo più prezioso perché
se prendiamo lingotto d'oro quello sta
fumetto nel caveau della banca quello
non si muoverà non cambierà il suo peso
non verrà attaccato dagli agenti
atmosferici è un materiale inerte per
definizione se volete
l'oro in questa forma lingotto è formato
da una quantità di atomi grandissima 10
alla 23 ossia 10 con 22 zeri dietro è un
numero che non possiamo nemmeno
immaginarci ma se proviamo a fare
un'operazione di rimpicciolimento cioè
prendiamo un aggregato di atomi di oro
ma che abbia soltanto mille
110 atomi di oro la materia oro
l'elemento è sempre lo stesso ma si
comporterà in modo completamente diverso
per esempio avrà un importante ruolo in
fenomeni e reazioni chimiche come ad
esempio la rottura delle molecole
d'acqua che se volete è uno dei pilastri
su cui si sta cercando di costruire
il nuovo carburante di domani cioè la
produzione di idrogeno
questo è soltanto un piccolo esempio ma
vedete come la quantità di elementi in
natura sia grande e le possibilità siano
infinite
a volte mi viene in mente quando bisogna
costruire un nuovo materiale
mi vengono in mente quelle vecchie
ferramenta in cui ci sono queste
grandissime cassettiere piene di varie
cose vari oggetti che uno potrebbe
perdersi a cercare di capire dove stanno
tutti questi oggetti
questa l l'entità delle possibilità che
abbiamo davanti
nuovi materiali ci potranno condurre a
applicazioni a nuove tecniche
industriali che potranno risolvere tanti
dei problemi che abbiamo che abbiamo nel
nostro mondo potranno potremo creare
materiali più sostenibili da un punto di
vista ambientale più equi
più ecologici
in questo modo noi riusciremo a dare
come fisici un contributo essenziale
allo sviluppo dei problemi del pianeta
ma al di là di questo di questo
risvolto
quello che ci deve sempre guidare e
monitorare e guidare ed indirizzare è
sempre la curiosità è sempre se volete
quel sentimento di essere un po bambini
che vanno a scoprire un mondo che non
hanno mai visto
io mi sento
calamitato dal perché questi oggetti si
comportino così in questo modo è quello
dovrà essere sempre sempre il nostro
spirito nel guardare avanti
saremo in grado di guardare avanti
soltanto se non perderemo l'innocenza di
questo spirito curioso grazie
[Applauso]